[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend Niedersachsen hat gewählt und in
mindestens einer Hinsicht war es auch
eine niedersachsen-wahl
spd-ministerpräsident Stefan weil konnte
seinen persönlichen Amtsbonus voll
ausspielen die Schwachen
Umfrageergebnisse für die Bundes-SPD
haben ihn nicht so geschadet wie von
manchen Sozialdemokraten befürchtet bei
den anderen Parteien sieht das anders
aus da lassen sich bundespolitische
Wirkungen sehr viel stärker ablesen und
Matthias vornauf präsentiert uns das
jetzt erstmal die neuesten Zahlen ja und
die neue Hochrechnung die beantwortet
mindestens einer offene Frage die wir
bis vor kurzem offen war so viel kann
ich vorweg sagen aber der Reihe nach die
SPD kommt auf 33,4 Prozent die CDU unter
30 bei 28,0 die Grünen 14,6 die FDP mit
4,8 ziemlich sicher nicht im Element
vertreten die AFD elf Prozent und die
Linke die schon nicht drin war kommt
erst recht diesmal nicht rein mit 2,7
Prozent wir schauen kurz auf die Gewinne
und Verluste das lohnt sich weil sich so
viel bewegt hat in den letzten fünf
Jahren wir gucken uns die beiden
Hauptgewinner an das sind die Grünen mit
sechs Punkten fast Zuwachs und die AFD
mit fast fünf Punkten Zuwachs und
verloren haben die SPD obwohl sie
Wahlsieger ist mehr als drei Punkte die
CDU mehr als fünf Punkte und die FDP
mehr als zwei Punkte kurzer Blick auf
die Sitzverteilung weil sich da etwas
verändert hat in den letzten Stunden die
Größe des Landtags jetzt 146 Sitze weil
die SPD mehr Erststimmen gewonnen
gewonnen hat als ihr nach dem
Zweitstimmen zustünde dafür gibt es
Überhangmandate die werden teilweise
ausgeglichen für die anderen Parteien
und das ist jetzt die wichtige Zahl 74
Sitze braucht man für die absolute
Mehrheit und wir schauen mal was das
heißt fürs Regieren in Niedersachsen
die bisher amtierende große Koalition
die würde es natürlich locker schaffen
über die Grenze von 74 mit 104 sitzen
aber die ist politisch von beiden nicht
mehr wirklich gewollt für Rot-Grün mit
81 reicht es auch relativ deutlich und
für Schwarz-Grün würde es nicht reichen
selbst wenn es politisch gewollt wäre so
viel zu den Zahlen Dankeschön Mathias ja
eine rot-grüne Koalition also möglich
und wahrscheinlich Ministerpräsident
weil hat im Wahlkampf ja auch immer
gesagt dass er sie nach Möglichkeit will
und damit wäre die letzte große
Koalition in einem deutschen Landtag
beendet die Zeit der deutschen grokos
und von denen gab es in Bund und Ländern
ja einige wäre dann erstmal vorbei diese
und andere interessante Erkenntnisse
dieses Wahltages fast an seinem Stern
zusammen
beim sozialdemokratischen Jubel heute
Abend ist ein bisschen Schadenfreude und
eine ganze Menge Erleichterung dabei
darüber dass die SPD dann doch deutlich
vor der CDU liegt und darüber dass er
sehr sicher auch in Zukunft der
Ministerpräsident von Niedersachsen sein
wird wir haben gekämpft
und wir erinnern uns lieber
[Applaus]
Freund Nation im niedersächsischen
Landtag die Wählerinnen und Wähler haben
der SPD den Regierungsauftrag erteilt
und niemand anders sonst Stefan weil SPD
feiert und bleibt also wohl der
mächtigste Mann im Land Bernd Althusmann
CDU wollte das unbedingt werden vom Kopf
an Kopf Rennen von der echten Chance
hatte er im Wahlkampf immer gesprochen
jetzt verliert er wieder gegen weil wie
schon 2017 diesmal wird er hin dieses
Votum nehmen wir demütig an auch ich
persönlich nehme dieses Votum an ich
werde dem Landesvorstand morgen
vorschlagen dass ich für das nächste Amt
des Landesvorsitzenden nicht mehr zur
Verfügung stehe
und so sieht das Gegenteil aus in Sachen
Stimmungslage die Grünen freuen sich
über das beste Ergebnis bei einer
Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen es wäre
möglicherweise noch besser geworden ohne
Störfeuer aus Berlin in Hannover wollen
sie nun regieren zusammen mit der SPD
ich denke das werden wir dann auch
voranbringen
mitregieren wollen eigentlich auch sie
die Freien Demokraten von Stefan Birkner
die jetzt allerdings extrem Zittern um
den Einzug in den Landtag aktuell sieht
es nicht nach einem Einzug aus ich denke
ich kann für uns alle sprechen dass wir
uns das nicht ganz so spannend
vorgestellt haben wie sich das jetzt
abzeichnet bangen bei der FDP kräftig
klatschen bei der AFD klar zweistellig
selbst erklärtes Wahlziel damit fast
erreicht wir haben unser Wahlergebnis
verdoppelt das was ich gesagt habe dank
euch
Niedersachsen hat gewählt neue
Machtverhältnisse im Landtag die Macht
des regierungsauftrages liegt nun bei
der SPD und bei Stefan Stefan einmal
noch kurz zurück Stefan weil der die
Bühne ohne Blumen verlassen wollte er
bekam sie noch zusammen mit noch mehr
Applaus für den Wahlsieg in
Niedersachsen
[Applaus]
tja und so wie die Bundespolitik in die
niedersachsenwahl hineinspielt so schaut
es jetzt aus Hannover natürlich auch
zurück nach Berlin für die FDP ist das
Ergebnis ziemlich desaströs das kann man
wohl so sagen und es wirft die Frage auf
wie Sie sich künftig in der Ampel
aufstellen will oder die Christian
Lindner ist am Abend schon formuliert
hat sie ihre Rolle überdenken
ja dazu gleich sprechen wir gleich noch
und wir sprechen gleich auch natürlich
noch mit dem Wahlsieger einiges zu
überdenken haben auch die CDU und
Friedrich Merz für die lief es auch
nicht wirklich gut und die SPD kann zwar
erleichtert sein aber sich keineswegs
erleichtert zurücklehnen dazu gibt
dieses Ergebnis dann auch keinen Anlass
und für die Grünen haben die Kompromisse
die sie gemacht haben und die Probleme
die bei der Umsetzung Stichwort
Wirtschaftsministerium der Politik
auftraten auch wahrscheinlich Punkte
gekostet ganz anders bei der AFD die
kann sich als krisengewinnerin fühlen
und während die Linken ein ähnliche
Strategie verfolgte wurde sie abgestraft
die Reaktionen aus Berlin hat uns wie
die Hecher zusammengefasst
in der Parteizentrale der SPD wirkt
Saskia esken ziemlich allein zu Hause
leere Stille keine Wahlparty nicht mal
hier
die SPD hat nicht geglänzt aber die Wahl
gewonnen und Askin Arndt wohl dass es in
der Ampel nicht leichter werden wird wir
müssen ja angesichts der Krise in Europa
den Krieg den wir haben der
energiepreiskrise auch
verantwortungsvoll regieren und sehr uns
nicht mit mit
einzelnen Situationen und
Schwierigkeiten befassen vor allem nicht
gegeneinander und das werden wir auch
weiterhin tun
Landtagswahl und Landtagswahl hat die
FDP hier nicht zu feiern in diesem Jahr
die Partei sitzt in der Patsche sie
sucht ihre Rolle und auch der Parteichef
findet kein Rezept man fühlt sich
missverstanden deshalb werden wir uns
die Frage vorlegen müssen in der
nächsten Zeit wie wir die entscheidenden
lösungsbeiträge der FDP die Rolle der
FDP der Ampelkoalition so auch
profilieren dass die Wählerinnen und
Wähler die eine liberale Partei der
Mitte unterstützen wollen die FDP auch
genau als diese Partei erkennen Probleme
verkannt zu werden hat die AFD nicht
angstschüren Wut einsammeln das hat
verfangen im Westen Deutschlands für uns
geht es immer um das Land und was wir
gerade erleben wir stehen auch an der
Schwelle eines Dritten Weltkrieges auch
das muss man mal klar benennen keine
andere Partei benennt überhaupt dieses
Problem dass diese Eskalationsstufe die
auch von unserer Bundesregierung oder
von Personen wie Frau Strack Zimmermann
oder auch selbst Friedrich Merz immer
weiter vorangetrieben wird das sorgt die
Leute apropos Friedrich Merz der hatte
mal versprochen als Parteichef die AFD
zu halbieren heute blieb er als einziger
Parteichef unsichtbar die Schuldfrage
Laden andere bei der Landes CDU ab wenn
Friedrich Merzig nicht so eingesetzt
hätte meine Meinung wäre das Ergebnis
schlechter gewesen die Menschen wollen
Stabilität und Herr weil hat diese
Stabilität diesen Menschen anscheinend
gegeben das hat man respektieren und so
ist es gelaufen gelaufen bei der Linken
ist schon früh das Licht aus die Partei
hat keine Antwort auf ihre Niederlagen
und die Grünen Wissen wieder sie können
sich auf gute Umfragen nicht verlassen
die Ampel trägten diese Zeit eine
riesengroße Verantwortung wir müssen die
Menschen durch den Winter bringen und
ich glaube das hat man ja gerade auch
bei Herr Lindner gehört dazu stehen wir
alle weiterhin bereit und davon werden
wir morgen und die Wochen danach
gemeinsam daran arbeiten da ist es
wieder das Beschwören des Zusammenhalts
die FDP wird es gehört haben beweisen
muss es die gesamte Ampel
so und jetzt ist uns erstmal der Wahl
Sieger zugeschaltet Ministerpräsident
Stefan weil gratulation und guten Abend
nach Hannover Herr Wahl
hören sie mich herbei hallo Frau
schlomka hören sie mich ja
sie mich auch ich höre sie gut ich höre
sie nicht gut das ist das Problem das
ist ja ziemlich trubelig also sie
müssten es vielleicht mit mir mehr Leute
und deutlich probieren ja ich versuch's
mal ich schreibe mal ein bisschen also
als loyaler Sozialdemokrat werden sie
jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen nee ist nicht
aber eigentlich sagt heute abend jemand
jeder der Herr Wahl der hat trotz Olaf
Scholz und der Ampelkoalition gewonnen
ja sie haben mir die Antwort
vorweggenommen das ist nicht so ich habe
absoluten Respekt vor der Arbeit die
Olaf Scholz und die Regierung in Berlin
derzeit zu leisten haben das mit Abstand
die schwierigste Situation in der sich
jemals eine Bundesregierung wieder
befunden hat und ich halte überhaupt
nichts davon jetzt immer zu sagen was
vielleicht an dieser oder jeden Stelle
immer noch hätte besser laufen können
das bringt uns überhaupt nicht weiter
ich habe meinen ganzen Wahlkampf nicht
mit einer Opposition gegen Berlin
bestritten sondern wenn erstens mit dem
Ausdruck von Respekt und zweitens mit
eigenen Vorschlägen die aber Substanz
haben
ein Ergebnis an diesem Wahlamt dass das
muss sie trotzdem betrügen das ist das
extrem starke Abschneiden der AFD die
auch von der SPD Wähler dazu gewonnen
hat sie regieren dieses Land das kann
ihn eigentlich nicht egal sein die
Niedersachsen ist eigentlich kein
traditionsland für radikale
ja also sie merken was wir gerade im
Hintergrund los ist und da muss ich
wirklich um Verständnis bitten ich habe
mir diesen senderort hier gerade nicht
ausgedacht ich fürchte das wird mit uns
beiden heute nicht ganz einfach werden
okay ich versuche es noch mal wie
erklären Sie sich das stärker
Abschneiden der AFD
naja die Antwort liegt glaube ich
ziemlich auf der Hand in einer Situation
in der sich viele Menschen absolut
nachvollziehbarer Weise sehr viele
Sorgen machen da liegt die Versuchung
nahe ist einfach den da oben auch mal zu
zeigen und wenn ich es recht verstanden
habe gibt es Umfragen die sagen dass die
Mehrheit der Wählerinnen und Wähler der
AFD selber sagt sie wählen die AFD nicht
Vertrauen in diese Partei haben sondern
weil sie ihren Protest zum Ausdruck
bringen wollen für mich lautet die
Schlussfolgerung dafür raus dass wir
durch gute Politik das Vertrauen auch
von solchen Menschen zurückgewinnen
können das liegt an uns selber und so
muss es glaube ich in der Demokratie
auch sein also das ist für mich der
große Wermutstropfen des heutigen Abends
aber es ist etwas was ich eher als
Auftrag empfinde und daran will ich
gerne mitarbeiten es heißt ja immer
große Koalitionen stärken die Ränder
kann es helfen wenn sie jetzt keine
große Koalition mehr fortsetzen sondern
mit den Grünen koalieren
ach das weiß ich nicht wir haben
durchaus die Erfahrung gemacht muss ich
sagen dass wir in der Pandemie
Niedersachsen gut zusammengearbeitet
haben zwischen den beiden großen und da
gab es dann auch Zustimmung ich glaube
am Ende ist es immer abhängig davon dass
man überzeugende Ergebnisse hat die auch
gut zu kommunizieren sind dann sind
Menschen nach meinen Erfahrungen bereit
auch in schwierigen Situationen zu sagen
okay das macht Sinn da gehe ich mit es
liegt ich wiederhole es einfach noch mal
eben zu einem guten Stück an uns selber
und diese dieser Einsicht die nehme ich
jedenfalls aus diesem Wahlkampf mit denn
ich habe natürlich auch viele
Diskussionen mit Menschen gehabt die am
Ende wahrscheinlich nicht die SPD
gewählt haben so sehr ich mich bemüht
habe aber ich danke Ihnen für das
Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen auch auf Wiederhören
tschüss
so und der nächste Gesprächspartner
steht auch schon bereit mal sehen ob es
da genauso laut ist oder nicht etwas
besser versteht Christian dürr
Vorsitzende der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion und selbst auch
Niedersachse guten Abend Herr dürr
guten Abend Frau man sieht schon so ein
bisschen an ihrem Gesichtsausdruck das
ist ein ziemlich desaströser Abend für
die FDP der FDP-Chef hat schon gesagt
wir müssen unsere Rolle in der
Ampelkoalition Überdenken der
Generalsekretär bläst eigentlich ins
gleiche Horn und sagt wir haben da
Riesenprobleme dass das klingt ein
bisschen panisch
es geht nicht um Panik Frau Slomka wir
haben Verantwortung und sehr schwierigen
Zeiten übernommen und da Sie Stefan Wall
gerade im Interview haben lassen nicht
das bitte sagen ein Glückwunsch an die
niedersächsische SPD und Stefan weil als
Ministerpräsidenten der ja auch wieder
in Zukunft sein wird das muss man
anerkennen gleichwohl das Ziel in der
Ampel ist das Deutschland aus der Mitte
regiert wird das wäre auch unser Ziel
für Niedersachsen gewesen und das hat
eindeutig nicht geklappt deswegen ist
das ein bitterer Wahlamt da gibt es auch
nicht zu beschönigen ja und jetzt noch
mal meine Frage welche Konsequenzen sie
dann im Hinblick auf die Bundesamtes
ja es bringt jetzt nichts heute Abend
über Konsequenzen bereits zu reden
sondern es geht jetzt darum zu schauen
was das Ergebnis insgesamt bedeutet und
natürlich was unsere Rolle in der Ampel
ist das Ziel ist wie gesagt Deutschland
aus der Mitte heraus zu regieren wir
regieren zusammen in Berlin mit zwei
strukturell eher linken Parteien mit
Sozialdemokraten und Grün das ist
herausfordernd als wir die Koalition
eingegangen sind wussten wir um die
Schwierigkeiten im Grundsatz aber
natürlich nicht um die katastrophale
Kriegssituation um die Energiekrise und
da waren wir in den letzten Wochen ja
auch sehr deutlich und vehement und
haben uns da auch von Koalitionspartnern
Unterschieden jetzt müssen wir in der
Ampel schauen wie das weitergeht denn
wir werden in den kommenden Wochen ganz
wichtige Entscheidung für Deutschland
treffen müssen und wir sind in
Verantwortung gegangen nach der
Bundestagswahl weil damals die Union
nicht regierungsfähig war und wir
stellen uns natürlich auch jetzt der
Verantwortung das ist doch klar aber
schwierig ist es da will ich auch nichts
beschönigen haben Sie denn vielleicht
auch selbst Fehler gemacht weil wenn man
so die Statements des Abends hört dann
hört man vor allem die haben sich auf
unsere Kosten profiliert und das war
alles viel zu Link und der Herr Lindner
muss das alles bezahlen was eine Natur
der Sache liegt man Finanzminister ist
wo hat denn die fdp-strategische Fehler
gemacht in diesem ersten Bundestagswahl
ja
also Frau Tomke als drei Demokrat liegt
die Eigenverantwortung sozusagen in
unserer DNA deswegen geht man natürlich
selbstkritisch mit sich um und muss sich
fragen wie inwiefern man richtig
arbeitet ist doch ganz
selbstverständlich gerade nach einer
Wahl Niederlage wie heute in
Niedersachsen
dass man nicht Verantwortung dass das
heißt nicht dass man nicht Verantwortung
übernehmen will und ich will ihn an
einem Punkt ist festmachen sehr konkret
sogar mich bei der Frage wie gehen wir
jetzt auch finanziell und von Startseite
den letzten Wochen ist der Eindruck in
der Bundespolitik entstanden dass der
Staat alles finanzieren könne das haben
dem haben wir teilweise widersprochen
aber in der Ampel das muss man so klar
sagen ist bei Sozialdemokraten und
Grünen dieser Eindruck nach wie vor da
wahrscheinlich müssen wir deutlicher
machen dass in so einer Krise man nicht
alles nur mit Staatsgeld zu kippen kann
sondern man jetzt auch energiepolitische
Entscheidungen denken Sie an die
Kernenergie beispielsweise treffen muss
und das ist die Aufgabe der FDP das ist
keine leichte Aufgabe dann mache ich mir
überhaupt nichts vor aber wir haben da
bestimmte Rolle nicht aus der Mitte
heraus zu regieren und da werden wir uns
auch selbstkritisch überprüfen Frau auf
die Atomkraft das hat die CDU auch
versucht beides war aber jetzt in
Niedersachsen auch nicht so erfolgreich
ist das wirklich das Thema mit dem man
dann noch mal ganz großen Stimmen
Aufschwung bekommt
das würde ich anders sehen Frau Slomka
die CDU in Niedersachsen hat einen
Wahlkampf gemacht mit einem einzigen
Inhalt nämlich gegen die Ampel und das
ist zu wenig es reicht ja nicht aus als
Politiker an Verantwortung und zumal wir
als Freie Demokraten auf bundesebenen
Regierungsverantwortung einfach nur zu
sagen wo gegen man ist sondern man muss
schon deutlich sagen wofür man ist und
da haben wir Konfliktpunkte in der Ampel
das ist öffentlich bekannt und da werden
wir jetzt in den kommenden Wochen
sicherlich auch mit den
Koalitionspartnern darüber reden müssen
wie die entschieden werden denn nochmal
die einfache Antwort dass man einfach
nur mehr Schulden macht das ist nicht
die Antwort der FDP und deswegen geht es
jetzt darum konzentriert arbeiten auf
der einen Seite aber sich natürlich auch
selbstkritisch überprüfen das gehört
eben genauso dazu aber ich bin nicht der
Auffassung dass man am Ende des Tages
sagen sollte wir wollen keine
Verantwortung die wollen wir sehr wohl
aber gleichzeitig muss man sich eben
stetig überprüfen und nochmal da stehen
jetzt ganz ganz wichtige Entscheidung an
wir haben Verantwortung in einer
schwierigen Zeit übernommen und jetzt
geht es auch dazu zu stehen zu dieser
Verantwortung also wir ahnen das gibt
noch einige Konflikte in Berlin Herr
dürr danke für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen Frau Slomka
so Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen und
ihrer bundespolitischen Bedeutung jetzt
ein Kommentar von der Chefredakteurin
des ZDF Bettina Schausten
die letzte Wahl in diesem Krisenjahr und
drei Lehren daraus erstens die SPD kann
gewinnen ein beliebter Amtsträger
sympathisch und glaubwürdig macht das
Rennen das ist klassisch für eine
Landtagswahl bei der sich die Menschen
zumal in Krisenzeiten hinter dem
vertrauten versammeln wenn sie ihm denn
Vertrauen Olaf Scholz im Kanzleramt wird
durch das Wahlgeschenk aus Hannover ein
Stück weit entlastet sollte daraus aber
keinen allzu großen Vertrauensbeweis in
seine Person ableiten Stefan weil hat
mehr trotz als wegen Olaf Scholz
gewonnen
zweitens die CDU kann mit Attacke auf
die Ampel nichts gewinnen und ist längst
nicht so stark wie es der
Bundesvorsitzende März proklamiert nicht
die Stärke der CDU wird der Berliner
Ampel gefährlich sondern die Schwäche
der FDP für die Liberalen geht ein
katastrophales Wahljahr zu Ende dem
Vorsitzenden Lindner ist es nie gelungen
das Versprechen an seine Welle
einzulösen Korrektiv für Rot-Grün zu
sein der grüne Erfolg übrigens sieht
größer aus als er ist im Plus schlummert
auch ein harbeck-dämpfer sagen wir es so
Schwein gehabt
und schließlich drittens die große
Mehrheit in Niedersachsen hat die
demokratische Mitte gewählt doch Krieg
und Krise werden bedrohlicher davon
profitiert die AFD gegen explodierende
Energiepreise und Inflation braucht es
jetzt konkrete Konzepte keine
Beruhigungspillen in comicsprache denn
wo soll das hinführen so ein Wahlabend
im Ductus des doppelwumms Klänge dann so
FDP am Boden Carbon CDU geknickt zack
grüne weniger stark als gedacht Boeing
AFD ojemine und die ampelperspektive
Bumm Krach Peng im Ernst bitte nicht die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wollen und
brauchen Antworten der Wahlkampf ist
vorbei jetzt bitte dringend zur Sache es
eilt
Bettina Schausten kommentiert Zahlen
Analysen und Hintergründe finden Sie bei
uns natürlich auch reichlich online auf
ZDF heute und jetzt erstmal andere
Nachrichten des Tages die hat Hanna
zimmermann
nach der Sabotage an zwei
kommunikationskabeln bei der Deutschen
Bahn hat der Staatsschutz des
Landeskriminalamts Berlin die
Ermittlungen übernommen ein politischer
Hintergrund sei nicht auszuschließen
erklärte eine Sprecherin gleichzeitig
mehren sich die Forderungen nach einem
besseren Schutz der Infrastruktur grünen
Chef nuripur sagte dafür sei mehr Geld
und eine bessere Verzahnung von Bund und
Ländern nötig der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der Unionsfraktion frei
schlug den Einsatz von Drohnen und
Sensortechnik vor
auch in Österreich gab es heute eine
Wahl nämlich die des Bundespräsidenten
das Ergebnis eindeutig Alexander van der
Bellen bleibt für sechs weitere Jahre im
Amt schon im ersten Wahlgang konnte sich
der 78-Jährige die absolute Mehrheit
sichern laut vorläufigem amtlichen
Endergebnis kommt der auf
54,6 Prozent eine Stichwahl ist damit
nicht nötig van der Bellen trat als
unabhängiger Kandidat an Ausnahme der
FPÖ unterstützen ihn alle wichtigen
Parteien
bundesinnenministerin Fräser will
offenbar den Präsidenten des Bundesamtes
für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik Schönbohm abberufen
das berichten mehrere Medien
übereinstimmend Hintergrund sind
mögliche Kontakte schön Booms zu
russischen Geheimdienst kreisen über
denen umstrittenen Verein
cyber-sicherheitsrat Deutschland zuvor
hatte das ZDF-Magazin Royal darüber
berichtet aus ministeriumskreisen
Release ist dass die für Donnerstag
geplante Vorstellung des
bsi-lageberichts zusammen mit Phaser
verschoben werde
die Protestwelle in iran@ mehr als drei
Wochen nach dem Tod der 22-jährigen
machsa Amini nicht ab auch an diesem
Wochenende gingen die Menschen in
zahlreichen Städten auf die Straße und
das trotz des gewaltsamen Vorgehens der
Sicherheitskräfte die Proteste machten
dabei auch vor dem iranischen
Staatsfernsehen nicht Halt durch einen
mutmaßlichen Heck wurde das Programm
kurzzeitig unterbrochen zu lesen war die
Botschaft steht auf und schließt euch
uns an
das ist auffällig wie lange sich die
russische Seite bedeckt hielt mit
offiziellen Reaktionen auf die Explosion
auf der krimbrücke und sogar erstmal das
Augenmerk auf einen russischen LKW
richtete als möglichen Verursacher die
Ukrainer spielten diese Karte ebenfalls
und raunten der Anschlag sei
möglicherweise Ausdruck interner Kämpfe
im russischen Machtapparat
was tatsächlich die Explosion ausgelöst
hat wissen wir immer noch nicht aber die
russische Führung hat sich jetzt
entschieden was sie dazu sagen möchte
die Ukrainer seines gewesen das ist
einerseits ein Eingeständnis der Feind
konnte unser bestbewachtes was diese
Objekt attackieren
andererseits lassen sich damit jetzt
auch Racheaktionen begründen Christiane
Hoffmann berichtet
mitten in der Nacht kamen die russischen
Raketen Augenzeugen sprechen von einem
Dutzend sie schlugen in mehrere
Wohngebäude der südukrainischen Stadt
saporisa ein mindestens 17 Menschen sind
tot Dutzende verletzt so die ukrainische
Regionalverwaltung die Überlebenden im
Schock wie die 73-Jährige Tatjana
lassunko und ihr Mann die die
Explosionen in ihrer Wohnung erlebten
wir saßen hier zwischen den Wänden auf
dem Stuhl alles ist durch die Gegend
geflogen ich habe geschrien hier gibt es
kein Militär keine Fabriken warum
bombardieren Sie uns
an andere Stelle wurden mehrere Häuser
komplett zerstört am Morgen danach
begannen Helfer aufzuräumen der
ukrainische Präsident selensky sprach
von einer bösartigen terroristischen
Attacke auf Zivilisten einen Tag nach
den Explosionen auf der krimbrücke die
Russland mit der besetzten Halbinsel
verbindet wurden zwei der vier
Fahrspuren für Autos freigegeben der
Nachschubweg für Putins Armee bleibt
empfindlich gestört die Russen stehen
jetzt hier im Stau
sie sagen uns die Fähren sind zu klein
sie können nur 20 Autos aufnehmen der
Stau hier ist 15 Kilometer das heißt wir
werden hier acht bis zehn Stunden stehen
der russische Präsident Putin gab am
Abend dem ukrainischen Geheimdienst und
Ausländern die Schuld an den Explosionen
es gebe keine Zweifel an einem Terrorakt
gegen russische zivile Infrastruktur so
Putin
und in der ukrainischen Hauptstadt Kiew
haben die Menschen die Explosionen auf
der krimbrücke auch wahrgenommen
durchaus mit gewisser Freude
das hat uns glücklich gemacht es war ein
guter Morgen im Hinterkopf haben wir
aber immer die Frage was die Folgen sein
werden die Lage ist gerade nicht so
einfach ein weiterer Tag im Ukraine
Krieg Russland scheint in der Defensive
doch die Kämpfe sind noch lange nicht
vorbei
und bei die hanna geht es mit den
Meldungen vom Sport von diesem
Wochenende weiter ja der Niederländer
Max Verstappen hat sich zum zweiten Mal
den Weltmeistertitel in der Formel 1
gesichert beim Großen Preis von Japan
landete Verstappen noch vor Teamkollege
Peres und Ferrari Pilot le Claire auf
dem ersten Platz nach einer
Regenunterbrechung und daraus folgender
Verwirrung um die Punktevergabe stand
dann fest der Titelverteidiger ist bei
den vier noch ausstehenden Rennen nicht
mehr von Platz 1 zu verdrängen und
steigt damit in den Kreis der
mehrfachweltmeister auf
beim Finale der Tischtennis-WM in China
hat die deutsche Nationalmannschaft den
Weltmeistertitel verpasst das Team von
Trainer Rosskopf unterlag wenig
überraschend den Favoriten und Langzeit
Siegern aus China mit 0:3 die Freude
über die erlangte Silbermedaille war
dennoch groß zumal das Team aus WM-Final
Debütanten bestand
am 9 spieltag der Fußball-Bundesliga gab
es heute drei Begegnungen das reinderby
Borussia Mönchengladbach gegen den 1 fC
Köln endete 5 zu 2 Hertha BSC und der SC
Freiburg trennten sich zwei zu zwei und
die Partie VfB Stuttgart gegen den
ersten fC Union Berlin endete mit 0:1
die nächste Woche wird innenpolitisch
natürlich noch sehr unter dem Eindruck
der niedersachsenwahl stehen was uns
darüber hinaus dass Weltgeschehen noch
an Ereignissen bescheren würde in diesen
Zeiten wissen wir nicht aber einige
Termine sind natürlich vorhersehbar
unser Ausblick von Jörg will
[Musik]
die unvollversammlung wird sich morgen
in einer Dringlichkeitssitzung mit der
Annexion der vier ukrainischen Gebiete
durch Russland befassen erwartet wird
eine Resolution die die Annexion
verurteilt Russland kann kein Veto
einlegen völkerrechtlich verbindend wäre
die Resolution aber nicht
knapp eine Million ukrainische
Kriegsflüchtlinge dazu steigende
Asylbewerberzahlen aus anderen Ländern
am Dienstag will sich
bundesinnenministerin Fräser mit
kommunalen Verbänden über die
Unterbringung der geflüchteten
austauschen Ziel des Gipfels eine
bessere Verteilung
es wird das erste hochrangige treffen
auf nato-ebene nach der Annektion der
russisch besetzten Gebiete am Mittwoch
werden die NATO Verteidigungsminister in
Brüssel zusammenkommen die wichtigste
Frage wie verhält sich das atlantische
Bündnis angesichts dieser neuerlichen
Eskalation
die bundesdelegierten Konferenz der
Grünen ab Freitag könnte zu einer
Zerreißprobe für die Partei werden ein
größter Streitpunkt der geplante AKW
streckbetrieb nach drei digitalen
corona-parteitagen werden die
Delegierten in Bonn erstmals wieder
physisch zusammenkommen
und so wird voraussichtlich das Wetter
in den kommenden Tagen die Aussichten
morgen teils Dorner teils Wolken am
Nachmittag von Nordwesten her Regen ganz
im Westen und Süden vereinzelt Schauer
Höchstwerte 15 bis 22 Grad in den
nächsten Tagen meist ruhiges Wetter mit
einer Mischung aus Sonne Wolken und
Nebel am Donnerstag im Süden wieder
Regen 13 bis 18 Grad
und zum Abschied jetzt noch etwas
Schönes das tut doch gerade in diesen
Zeiten gut Musik Klassik zum Seelen
Trost und das schauen wir auf eine
besondere Künstlerin die
Mezzosopranistin lea desendre hat eine
commitenhafte Karriere gemacht sie
erwecke alles was sie anfasst zu leben
und Schönheit so die New York Times
heute wird sie in Berlin als Sängerin
des Jahres ausgezeichnet
[Musik]
klassikverleihung gibt es dann jetzt
gleich im Anschluss hier im Programm und
von uns beiden war es das an diesem
Sonntagabend um 0 Uhr gibt es dann hier
die nächsten heute Nachrichten und hier
melden sich morgen abend Hanna und
Christian Sievers auf Wiedersehen
tschüss
[Musik]